bonsoir l'otan réunis à bruxelles
s'apprête à adresser un ultimatum aux
serbes
ce n'est pas officiel mais la rumeur est
persistante depuis une heure environ
rejoignons tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial à bruxelles laurent bousquet
pour en savoir davantage de rein écoutez
il n'y a pas d'ultimatum mais ça en a la
saveur le goût et l'odeur il semble
qu'on soit un tournant l'otan va envoyer
un une injonction c'est le terme
diplomatique aux serbes de bosnie pour
qu'ils retirent leurs armes lourdes des
environs de sarajevo avec destruction
par frappes aériennes pour celles qui
seront encore sur place passé un certain
délai c'est une décision importante
parce que lourdes de conséquences pour
l'avenir
pourquoi les discussions elle était
aussi langue d'ailleurs elles ne sont
pas terminés à l'heure vous parlez
laurent dégoûté parce qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de détails à régler par exemple
on sait que depuis quelques jours les
experts militaires sont au travail et
non pas pour s'occuper des plans de
frapper rien ils sont prêts depuis
longtemps mais pour s'occuper de la
praye frappes aériennes des conséquences
sur les casques bleus pour les protéger
et pour éventuellement les évacuer
c'était une demande très importante des
canadiens qui a retardé un petit peu les
négociations merci laurent évidemment
vous restez en direct de bruxelles si la
décision est officielle n'hésitez pas à
intervenir au cours de ce journal et
pour avoir une idée du climat qui a
régné aujourd'hui au siège de l'otan
retour en arrière avec laurent doucier
philippe dias là une journée riche en
rebondissements au départ aucune
objection de principe de la part des 16
pays de l'alliance fermeté affichée
le texte franco américain servait de
base de travail à toutes les délégations
un texte qui avait le mérite d'être
simple retrait est mise sous contrôle de
l'onu de toutes les armes lourdes serbes
et bosniaques se trouvant dans ou autour
de sarajevo et éventuellement
destruction par frappes aériennes des
armes encore sur place passé un certain
délai c'était trop simple
les détails ont tout retardé par exemple
les grecs ne voulant pas entendre le mot
ultimatum on parle maintenant de délai
mais là aussi il faut discuter la france
et l'angleterre voulait 7 jours maximum
les autres 10 jours avec encore
réticences des grecs
autre exemple le retrait des armes
lourdes pour certains elle devait
s'éloigner de 20 km pour d'autres
km minimum bref des détails pratiques
qui ajoutait aux demandes canadienne sur
la sécurité de leurs troupes ont
entraîné discussions négociations et
interruption de séance
il faut dire quand même que la décision
finale étant lourde de conséquence
chaque mot est pesé et analysé plusieurs
fois ce n'est évidemment par hasard au
moment même où l'otan se réunissait à
bruxelles
si les serbes ont promis aujourd'hui de
retirer leurs armes lourdes autour de
sarajevo il en a même conclu un
cessez-le-feu avec les bosniaques
mais quelle valeur peut avoir une telle
promesse martine laroche-joubert le
général michael rose celle de la
forpronu en bosnie paraît plus détendu
qu'à l'ordinaire il ya de quoi
après ses entretiens avec les chefs
militaires serbes et bosniaques
il annonce à cesser le feu et le retrait
des armes lourdes par les serbes
c'est le début du jeu c'est très
important pour moi parce que pour la
première fois on a peut-être commencé
quelque chose qui va aboutir
qui sont ces chars en position sur les
montagnes autour de sarajevo qui
devraient être retirés dans le délai de
sept à dix jours décrété par l'otan
l'artillerie lourde serbes et bosniaques
serait ensuite placée sous le contrôle
de la forpronu les casques bleus
s'installerait sur ses positions
stratégiques à l'extérieur et à
l'intérieur de la capitale bosniaque
quel sera le périmètre de sécurité on
l'ignoré encore
une commission mixte devrait en décider
une mise en application certainement
difficile ce qui explique certaines
réticences ce soir du président et
d'égoïste il préfère attendre et voir ce
qui se passera effectivement sur le
terrain
un scénario presque irréelle où sarrail
et vous ne serez plus prise dans un étau
peut-être peut-être
il est vrai que les trêves ont été fort
nombreux dans cette guerre ait jamais
respecté jean-jacques le garrec vous
êtes à sarajevo
ce cessez-le-feu sera-t-il aussi
éphémère que les autres c'est la
question qui se pose ici
effectivement le général rose était très
déterminé cet après midi mais de belles
déclarations de ce style nous en avons
entendu souvent et les bosniaques sont
très prudents les accords qui ont été
signés soit après
10 les bosniaques y était allé avec deux
conditions d'une part retrait des armes
lourdes à plus de 30 km deuxièmement
dans un délai de cinq jours en or sur
ces deux conditions
pas de réponse il y a encore beaucoup
d'inconnues la seule chose qu'a dit le
général rose c'est que si dans les sept
jours on entend on ne voyait pas avant
c'est le début de cette de ces accords
il faudrait reconsidérer les motivations
de ceux qui les ont signés reconsidérer
les motivations c'est un langage que
l'on a souvent entendu ici reste
également pour la sécurité de la
population de sarajevo qu' on ne
considère dans cet accord que les armes
lourdes et tout ce qui est en dessous
des balles de 12 mm 7 c'est à dire tous
les snipers les tireurs d'élite qui
jonchent la ville dans tous les sens
risquent de revenir et d'être encore une
cible une menace en permanence pour une
population qui reste une cible reste
ensuite mais ce n'est qu'un premier pas
si cet accord devait marcher toute la
bosnie simplement ce premier pas montré
la détermination du général rose du
général kotte et de monsieur akashi ici
on a certainement très envie d'espérer
que ce soit un pas positif
merci jean jacques quand on vous garde
évidemment en direct ce cessez-le-feu
acceptée par les serbes a laissé de
marbre les membres de l'otan et
particulièrement les états unis dont
l'attitude a changé
prudent il y à peu il se montre
aujourd'hui déterminé jean-marc il vous
êtes vous en direct de washington
oui si vous voulez c'est une question de
rapport de force non seulement à
washington mais comme à sarajevo
les américains ont juré de ne plus se
laisser prendre au piège comme en
somalie des images télévisées des drames
télévisée et pourtant à défaut de
mobiliser l'opinion américaine
cette fois ci les images de sarajevo ont
remobilisé la classe politique
américaine sur un thème qui est très
délicat pour le président clinton
celui de leadership le leadership ça
veut dire la capacité d'assumer un rôle
dirigeant
qu'attendent tous les américains de leur
président en cas de crise
et cette fois-ci bill clinton
craignaient de perdre de l' influence au
congrès alors c'est vrai washington
aujourd'hui fait cause commune avec les
européens pour menacer les serbes
relancer des négociations mais pour
autant les américains ne sont pas prêts
à faire pression sur les bosniaques pour
leur faire accepter une solution
territoriale au rabais
cette volonté de punir les serbes s'ils
ne lèvent pas le siège de sarajevo n'est
cependant pas unanimes moscou continue
de s'opposer à une intervention me
r si l'avertissement de l'otan est
confirmée comment réagir et boris
eltsine rejoignent en direct de moscou
dominique derda dominique c'est bien
paul il n'y a pas encore de réaction
officielle du côté russe la dépêche
qu'il ya un seulement de tomber sur les
téléscripteurs de l'agencé tass on peut
toutefois tenter de l'advil à deviner
vous savez hier le vice ministre russe
des affaires étrangères a téléphoné à ce
mode milosevic pour le convaincre de
faire pression sur les serbes de bosnie
pour qu'il lève le siège de sarajevo
lyon c'est que demain les russes avaient
l'intention de proposer une nouvelle
initiative de paix à genève
sur le plan diplomatique donc ils ne
peuvent être que déçu et c'est un
euphémisme de ce nouveau pas vers un
engagement militaire de l'onu de l'otan
en bosnie et justement l'otan les
inquiète c'est rue s'ils n'en font pas
partie ils craignent de voir l'alliance
atlantique intervenir dans ce qu'ils
considèrent comme leur zone d'influencé
on n'en est pas encore bien sûr un
retour à la guerre froide mais pour la
première fois depuis longtemps depuis la
guerre du golfe sans doute les états
unis elle a reçu la russie se retrouvent
face à face sur un plan diplomatique car
si bill clinton a changé d'avis vous
venez de le dire au sujet de la bosnie
bill boris eltsine pardon boris eltsine
considèrent toujours qu'il ne faut
surtout pas intervenir militairement là
bas boris eltsine d'ailleurs dont on dit
que depuis hier il est malade et est
enrhumé parce qu'il fait très froid à
moscou il serait il ya fort à parier
qu'il réagisse et qu'il guérisse bien
vite
l'intervention militaire internationale
n'aura peut-être jamais lieu si les
serbes font preuve de sagesse mais tout
est prêt pour qu'elle ait lieu laurent
bouvier
depuis plusieurs mois ils observent ils
surveillent ils s'entraînent les
quelques 200 avions de chasse et de
bombardements de l'otan stationnées en
italie n'ont pourtant jusqu'à présent
jamais reçu l'ordre d'intervenir ni même
simplement celui d'ouvrir le feu au
dessus du territoire bosnien américains
français anglais hollandais espagnols
turcs stationnés au sol ou embarqués à
bord du porte-avions en ce moment le
saratoga américain et l'ark royal
anglais ils sont pourtant en permanence
tenue au courant des évolutions de la
situation sur le terrain des positions
des armes lourdes ou des dépôts de
munitions des différents belligérants
voilà alors ici on voit les casemates
qui vont sans doute apparaître voilà la
trousse les plans de frappes aériennes
sont donc prêts mais les experts
militaires savent aussi que pour
détruire les quelques 500 canons ou
pièces d'artillerie disséminés autour de
sarajevo
il faudra plusieurs raids aériens
pendant plusieurs jours des jours
pendant lesquels les casques bleus
stationnés au sol serait certainement et
pour simon justement françois mitterrand
aujourd'hui en conseil des ministres a
souligné la gravité du moment
edouard balladur au cours de la même
réunion a précisé chacun doit comprendre
que rien ne sera facile
une allusion au risque d'une éventuelle
frappe aérienne pour les casques bleus
de roter aux lyrics les soldats de 35
pays forment la forpronu la force de
protection des nations unies
depuis août 92 une résolution du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu définit sa mission
les casques bleus doivent protéger
l'acheminement de l'aide humanitaire en
bosnie la fonction n'est donc pas de
combattre mais bien d'aider les
populations civiles
pour cette mission ils sont près de
11000 déployés en bosnie parmi eux plus
de quatre mille casques bleus français
1600 sont à sarajevo 1300 dans la poche
de biatch le reste du contingent
français étant dispersés en bosnie
centrale si leur mission est purement
humanitaire les casques bleus disposent
cependant d'un droit de riposte en cas
de légitime défense
mais si des frappes aériennes de l'otan
se concrétisait les sonnets de l'onu
s'exposeraient à des représailles serbe
reste alors la solution du renfort des
casques bleus sur place ou de leur
retraite politiquement toujours
envisageable
n'oublions pas tout de même que l'otan
comme l'onu ont lancé à plusieurs
reprises des avertissements
avertissement sans effet de quoi rester
prudent sur la suite et gilles rabin
mars 93
après de longues hésitations le conseil
de sécurité des nations unies décrète
une interdiction générale de survol de
la bosnie l'otan'' est chargé de faire
respecter l'interdiction et les avions
du pacte atlantique patrouilles jour et
nous les avions de guerre serbe et
croate reste au sol mais pas les
hélicoptères des centaines de violations
ont été enregistrés jamais les nations
unies ne se sont décidés à les
sanctionner juin 93 la désobstruction et
des humiliations des foules
interminables et du racket que subissent
les soldats de l'onu à chaque contrôle
sur les routes du magny terre de bosnie
l'otan accepte de fournir un soutien
aérien aux casques bleus
sans résultat le secrétaire général des
nations unies ne permettra jamais la
riposte août 80 13 janvier 94 les pays
d'europe et les etats-unis ne peuvent
plus cacher qui ne s'accorde ni sur le
volet militaire ni sur le volet
diplomatique du plan pour la bosnie et
le fossé se creuse entre les militaires
et les diplomates de l'onu
c'est le général morillon acquis la
diplomatie des nations unies ne pardonne
pas d'avoir mis en lumière l'hiver
dernier la puissance des casques bleus à
srebrenica
c'est le général kotte qui demandent le
droit de riposter pour faire respecter
ces soldats
nous sommes obligés de mettre nos trois
orgueil dans notre poche ce qui parfois
difficile par contre ce que je n'accepte
pas ce que nous mettions notre honneur
dans notre poche
le secrétaire général de l'onu demandera
leur rappelle et le tiendra malgré tout
le 11 janvier dernier le sommet de
l'otan menacera d'utiliser les raids
aériens en riposte au blocus de tuzla et
srebrenica
là aussi sans résultat
et pourtant cette décision que l'otan
s'apprête à prendre d'une minute à
l'autre d'une heure à l'autre ne
semblent pas ressembler aux précédentes
edouard balladur l'a laissé entendre ce
matin philippe harrouard nous sommes at
il dit à un tournant je crois qu'il a
raison c'est un tournant car de deux
choses l'une ou bien les serbes retirent
leur artillerie comme promis mais ils
ont su
promis et jamais tenues ou bien l'otan
frappe
car cette fois la décision qui est en
train d'être prises à bruxelles sera
bonne
dans les deux cas recul des serbes ou
frappes aériennes c'est une première
cela prouve que rien n'est possible sans
unanimité des membres de l'otan et
surtout sans implication véritable des
états unis toute dissension entre
américains et européens on l'a bien vu
est exploité par les parties en conflit
pour rejeter un accord de paix et
redoubler la violence sur le terrain
c'est aussi un tournant parce qu'en cas
de frappes aériennes
on risque d'entrer dans un engrenage une
extension du conflit
c'est un risque calculé y compris par
rapport à la position russe pro serbes
dont sont conscients et les pays de
l'otan et surtout les états unis en tête
merci philippe si vous nous rejoignez en
ce moment même je vous rappelle donc
l'information que je dénie au début de
ce journal l'otan réunis à bruxelles
s'apprête à adresser un ultimatum aux
serbes de bosnie s'ils ne lèvent pas le
siège de sarajevo nous aurons peut être
une confirmation de ce qui n'est qu'une
rumeur
au cours de ce journal en france les
marins pêcheurs bretons décideront
seulement demain de l'arrêt ou non les
amarres ils ne sont pas parvenus à
prendre une décision aujourd'hui ils
étaient partagés sur les dernières
propositions du gouvernement mais le
mécontentement
préval et reportages au guilvinec d'
antoine cormery et jean-pierre à des
emballages de poids sont étrangers
brandis comme des trophées preuve pour
les pêcheurs de l'inefficacité des
mesures de contrôle des importations
pourtant prises par le gouvernement
l'importation pourquoi pas laisser
contrôler les camions les représentants
du comité de survie de retour de paris
ont beau s'époumoner expliqué que le
gouvernement a fait preuve de bonne
volonté rien n'y fait l'ambiance est
électrique
car dans le train de mesures annoncées
les patrons des petits bateaux moins de
12 mètres se sentent floués
mais comment satisfaire tout le monde le
comité de survie met en garde les
pêcheurs
s'isole ici à la pointe de bretagne et
que les autres partent en mer attention
à la reprise et à nos parts de marché
tout ce que vous voulez la réaction de
la base est alors immédiate au nom de la
solidarité des gens de mer
puis vint le vote de demain à bulletins
secrets dans tous les ports bretons
marquera donc un tournant il permettra
de mesurer concrètement la cohésion des
pêcheurs après 11 jours de grève on joue
pendant lesquelles aucun bateau n'est
sorti du port du guilvinec
vous l'avez entendu les plus mécontents
étaient les petits pêcheurs
propriétaires de bateaux de moins de 12
mètres
ils ont le sentiment de ne pas avoir été
entendu frédéric route à dominique
bonnet il a travaillé longtemps sur un
peut nier en afrique
mais pour être plus près de sa famille
il s'est acheté il y à onze ans de cela
un chalut de 12 m
ça vous manque la même
ces deux doigts de vie quoi je veux
juste majeur autre chose daniel déplore
bien sûr la baisse du cours du poisson
le problème des importations mais
surtout le crains le pire nous un
sentiment qu'on veut supprimer une
certaine partie de la phase 11 jeux pour
supprimer une certaine partie pour
laisser la place aux espagnols j'ai
prévenu déjà depuis longtemps on veut
pas nous le dire en clair mais pourquoi
les esprits ils sont plus compétitifs
que les français il reste beaucoup moins
cher expliqué noël le charges sociales
lapins et des mâles ou sur un bateau
espagnol
qu'est ce que vous croyez il ya le
patron jean mécaniciens qui ont une
bonne paye les autres c'est la monnaie à
ses côtés bernard il est patron d'un
bateau de 5 matelots il est totalement
solidaire de petits pêcheurs
alors si je sais pas si j'ai une
connerie fort mais que 5 euros si on
peut façonner plus offrant mais la
solidarité
daniel n'y croit plus il assiste à la
dernière réunion avant le vote de demain
il ne prendra pas la parole il remet son
destin et celui de sa famille dans les
bulletins de vote de ses collègues
découvrent maintenant
j'ai voulu confier le pêcheur n'est pas
qu'ils consentent non
sûrement pas
ce qui va faire je ne peux pas
je ne sais pas
vous connaissez la formule le temps
c'est de l'argent on peut désormais la
décliner autrement l'argent c'est du
temps c'est l'esprit d'un projet de loi
présenté en conseil des ministres par
michèle giro le ministre du travail
propose de transformer certaines primes
financières en temps libre qui
s'ajouterait évidemment aux vacances
habituel ce projet a un nom le compte
épargne temps on peut aussi dire
nouveaux congés payés jean-pierre
métivet échanger de l'argent qu'on prend
du temps c'est l'idée de ce projet de
loi sur la participation
là où ils existent dans les entreprises
de plus de 50 personnes ont créé un
compte épargne temps une sorte d'
enveloppe uche est salarié peut déposer
les jours de vacances qu'il ne prend pas
dans la limite de 10 jours par an
déposer aussi tout ou partie de ces
primes éventuelles
ou son 13e mois ils s'ajouteront à
l'argent déjà épargné au titre de la
participation avec cette cagnotte
un salarié pourra prendre du champ un
congé sans solde un départ temporaire
mais de 6 mois minimum précise la loi
pour qu'il y ait effets sur l'emploi
voilà pour les grandes lignes ce système
fera l'objet d'accords d'entreprise ou
de branche
dans la pratique c'est bien sûr une
mesure à moyen terme ou calcul au
ministère du travail qu'il faut 6
environ avant de pouvoir s'offrir six
mois de temps libre le tgv a quitté ce
matin à besançon à 6h01 il était attendu
à paris à 8h41 il a déraillé à 6h05
il n'y a pas une seule victime
christophe thorin la pièce à l'origine
du déraillement la voici un tampon tombé
d'un train de marchandises une demi
heure avant le passage du tgv besançon
paris l'a sorti du rail d'un des quatre
essieux d'une seule voiture est due à
l'arrêt d'urgence du train lancé à 105
kilomètres heure pour la sncf cet
incident ne peut en aucun cas être
comparée à d'autres quatre boulons mâle
fils fait serait à l'origine de la chute
de la pièce métallique
aucun des 200 passagers n'a été blessé
les voyageurs sont simplement arrivé à
paris avec deux heures de retard
le 9 février 92 un avion affrété par air
sénégal pour le club méditerranée
s'était écrasé en casamance au sénégal
il y avait eu 30 morts aujourd'hui les
survivants de l'accident et les familles
des victimes portent plainte pour
homicides et blessures involontaires
contre le club méditerranée isabelle
steiss roger moore
ce 9 février 1992
l'appareil affrété par air sénégal pour
le club
10 tehran et s'écrase en pleine brousse
à 52 kilomètres de sa destination finale
cap skirring le pilote a confondu la
piste d'atterrissage
avec cette année d'un village
touristique une erreur de navigation et
d'appréciation de l'équipage dit
aujourd'hui le rapport d expertise
accablant pour le pilote un américain de
67 ans alors que la retraite à 60 ans
l'homme souffrait de troubles auditifs
et de la vue et il était poursuivi par
la justice américaine pour infraction à
la réglementation aérienne
quant à l'appareil un conte vers 640
d'une société gambienne le rapport
relève de graves lacunes dans la
maintenance des équipements défectueux
notamment le système de repérage des
balises au sol il aura fallu deux ans
avant que les victimes obtiennent ce
rapport d expertise
aujourd'hui leur association porte
plainte contre le club méditerranée le
club méditerranée était selon nous
complètement informés des risques qu'il
faisait je prendre à ses passagers
puisque c'était la huitième fois que ce
vol était fait par le même avion le même
équipage et à chaque fois les passagers
c'était plat à l'arrivée 2
de la qualité du vol et des prestations
le club méditerranée a reconnu sa
responsabilité civile en accordant
réparation victimes
il a par ailleurs attaqué le
transporteur air sénégal qu'il rend
responsable des infractions à la
sécurité la justice française doit
maintenant déterminer si le voyagiste a
lui aussi commis des négligences qui ont
coûté la vie à 30 personnes
la loi est stricte à l'interdît de
commenter une décision de justice
pourtant huit jours après la
condamnation d'omar raddad pour le
meurtre de ghislaine marchal les
critiques abondent celle d'avocats de
magistrats d'intellectuels mais aussi et
c'est beaucoup plus rare de jurés qui
ont eu à juger le jardinier marocain
dominique verdeilhan innocent innocent
ce sont les seuls mots comme un raddad a
prononcé en français durant son procès
c'était le matin même du verdict des
mots que les jurés en grande majorité
n'ont pas voulu entendre par plus qu'ils
n'ont été convaincus par la défense
tardive de maître vergès
parmi les neuf jurés populaires
quelques-uns d'entre eux se sont confiés
à un journaliste de vsd
ils confient leur trouble ressenti tout
au long des sept heures de délibéré
soulignant comment selon eux la religion
du doute fut écarté un doute qui en
principe doit profiter à l'accusé
des confessions anonyme de jurer que la
loi interdit au nom du secret des
délibérés mais les confessions qui
illustrent au sein même de la cour
d'assises le malaise suscité par ce
verdict malaise ressenti aussi par des
intellectuels des artistes à l'appel du
journal globe 40 personnalités demandent
la tenue d'un autre procès mais
aujourd'hui seule la cour de cassation
peut en décider
solitude du juré en salle de
délibérations certains d'entre eux se
sont déclarés favorables à une
possibilité d'appel en cour d'assises
revendiquant ainsi publiquement leur
droit à l'erreur encore un effort
françaises français et notre pays
atteindra bientôt la barre des 60
millions d'habitants ce n'est pas encore
le cas
l'insee recense aujourd'hui près de 57
millions huit cent mille habitants
l'effort doit être soutenue parce que
l'insee a froidement constaté une baisse
des naissances une baisse des mariages
françoise david
mais l'honneur de ne pas te demander
danone est de plus en plus de français
sont d'accord avec georges brassens
en vingt ans le nombre de mariages
célébrés en france a chuté de 40%
seul en 1993 254 1000 couples ont
sacrifié au rite du oui prononcé devant
monsieur le maire de la photo de famille
et de la réception qui suit et quand ils
l'ont fait ils se sont donné le temps de
la réflexion
le nombre de mariages tardifs est en
hausse par rapport à l'union de jeunes
célibataires les maternités comme les
mairies connaissent elles aussi une
baisse de fréquentation
en 1993 les services de l'état civil ont
enregistré sept cent douze mille
naissances soit 31 mille bébés de moins
que l'année précédente
l'explication n'est pas nouvelle
meilleure maîtrise de la contraception
pour des femmes qui travaillent plus
longtemps et davantage à noter que la
france reste quand même l'un des pays
les plus dynamiques d'europe sur le plan
démographique les chinois s'envole ils
ont réussi la mise sur orbite de deux
satellites leurs fusées s'appelle longue
marche 3 leurs principaux clients les
américains patrick estève ne vous
laissez pas abuser par les uniformes
c'est bien d'un lancement de satellite
civil dont il s'agit et non pas d'un
missile militaire mais vous êtes en
chine au centre spatial de xichang et
vous assister au tout premier décollage
de la longue marche 3 derniers modèles
de la technologie chinoise
ce vol va être couronnée de succès et
les deux satellites scientifiques de
deux tonnes et demie vont être placés en
orbite depuis le début de son programme
spatial
la chine a déjà lancé 33 satellite pour
son propre usage
ainsi que trois satellites étrangers
mieux les dirigeants de pékin ont signé
un très gros contrat pour le lancement
de 20 satellites avec la société
américaine de radio téléphone motorola
la longue marche 3 dont les prix sont
très nettement inférieurs à ceux
pratiqués par arianespace pourrait
s'avérer être une redoutable concurrente
le grand spectacle sur tapis blanc va
bientôt commencer france télévisions est
prête pour les jeux olympiques de
lillehammer
vous aurez droit senteurs de programmes
grâce à nos 15 envoyés spéciaux et
évidemment toutes les équipes techniques
parmi eux françois brabant est déjà sur
place en éclaireur
vu d'en haut évidemment c'est calme à se
demander si c'est bien ici que doit se
dérouler dans trois jours une cérémonie
d'ouverture olympique et pourtant depuis
ce matin c'est fou ce qu'on s'active sur
le tremplin de lillehammer
une fanfare qui jouent des enfants qui
sautent les militaires qui dégivre avec
les moyens du bord
tout se met en place pour samedi 16
doucement tranquillement et secrètement
cette petite répétition est la seule que
nous pourrons film et on sait donc qu'il
y aura quelques danses folkloriques et
que la flamme arrivera dans euros pour
le reste il faudra attendre mais tout
est prêt tout la preuve
vu d'en bas c'est calme aussi
lillehammer 12000 habitants une rue
principale la voici
et c'est tout pas de foule pas de folie
pas de fièvre encore si ce n'est du côté
des japonais venus fêter les jeux de 98
à nagano
les norvégiens eux sont discrets mais
qu'on ne s'y trompe pas les norvégiens
sont fiers d'accueillir les jeux et ils
font déjà beaucoup beaucoup d'heureux
sur le faire bon on essaie peut-être de
rester tranquille je crois pour le
moment on n'a rien compris qu'on sait
pas que ça va se passer dans trois jours
donc un peu lent mais qu'est ce qui se
passe mais bien sûr nous fermons les
choses en parlant comment fait on dirait
que remplit tous les gens qui sont un
râteau sa souris puis c'est l'ambiance à
la fête
bref la norvège est comme ça elle
accueille les jeux olympiques d'hiver
mais n'en fait pas pour autant une
montagne de toute façon il reste trois
jours et quarante et une minutes
maintenant à lillehammer pour se
réveiller
les amateurs avaient rencontré les pros
du psg en coupe de france de football il
avait été battu 10 à 0 mais ils ont pris
goût ils ont réclamé de l'argent refus
du club déception des missions scandale
c'est à côte chaude à saint-etienne
françoise vallée jean claude martin
c'était le 22 janvier dernier
les 32e de finale côte-chaude battu par
le psg mais au stade geoffroy guichard
c'est la fait plus de trente mille
personnes sont venues soutenir l'équipe
d'honneur régionale c'était la plus
grosse affluence de la saison
malheureusement l'exaltation de dura
qu'un soir l'image d'une petite équipe
soudée était bien trompeuses
déjà avant le match la perspective d'une
recette exceptionnelle montait à la tête
de certains joueurs
le 4 janvier dans une lettre au maire
sept d'entre eux demandaient une
rémunération
réponse du maire adressez vous au club
mais à côte chaude on ne joue pas pour
de l'argent
on est à peu près 150 bénévoles et
jamais personne n'a été payée jamais
jamais jamais
mécontents les sept joueurs solidaires
ont démissionné la fête a tourné au
cauchemar
je pense que la plus grosse récompense
était de faire un 32e de finale et je
pense qu'ils n'ont pas compris mais je
pense qu'ils n'ont pas compris surtout
c'est que le club voulait voulait
récompenser les joueurs même largement
mais d'une façon habituelle c'est-à-dire
avec des avec une prime de match qui
sécurité dans la caisse et que tout le
monde devrait plus profiter
une récompense collective ici c'est la
coutume au club de côte chaude
les 32e de finale ont laissé un goût
amer comme les grands ils se sont fait
avoir par l'argent
l'opéra de paris change de président
hugues gall succédera à pierre bergé dit
opéra de paris j'ai commis une erreur il
s'agit désormais de l'opéra national de
paris
aller opéra bastille ou bilan des
premières notes entendues dans cette
cathédrale de verre et de béton par
georges b gouverneur pissos
dès 1988 date de la nomination de pierre
berger
malgré les tumultes et les polémiques
que l'opéra bastille sort de terre le
baptême musicale a lieu en mars 90 sous
le signe de l'audace avec les troyens de
berlioz quelques changements de tête
quelques grèves mais la vie artistique
du grand vaisseau en épousant la passion
de pierre bergé a maintenu le cap d'une
grande ambition suis pas toujours
content de ce que j'ai fait et soyons
clairs enfin c'était très émouvant de
faire cela et j'ai des très beaux
souvenirs
je voudrais dire que ce problème une des
choses les deux choses qui m'ont le plus
touché et que j'emporte avec moi
la première c'est d'avoir pu faire venir
un directeur musical qui s'appelle youn
chong un coréen et qui aujourd'hui
s'affirme comme un des plus grands chefs
de sa génération et qui en tout cas a su
transformer complètement leur qu'istres
de l'opéra pas
le deuxième chose c'est quand même le
public vous savez faire des
représentations d'opéras fois difficiles
et refusé du monde tous les jours ça
c'est quand même extraordinaire
donc ça veut dire que le pari a été tenu
parce que le public était là et et
suivants
sur demande si en vous nommant président
d'honneur on n'a pas installé à la
bastille une statue du commandeur pour
qu'il y ait une statue du commandeur
il faudrait qu'il y ait un donjon
l'avenir le dira
et parlons-en c'est à dire quelques mots
écoutez cet avenir moins je l'espère
beaucoup qu'il s'annonce sous les
meilleurs auspices il faut faire
confiance à l'équipe qui va être là
personnellement je fais confiance à
hugues gall qui a montré ses qualités
d'un professionnel et je connais très
bien je pense pour un diriger
efficacement que cette maison certains
d'entre vous n'ont sans doute pas
regardé le début du journal je vous
rappelle donc l'information que je
donnais à 20h le mot information n'est
pas approprié la rumeur qui nous
parviennent à bruxelles l'otan s'apprête
à adresser un ultimatum aux serbes de
bosnie si le siège de sarajevo n'est pas
levée il y aura intervention militaire
aérienne
les 16 membres de l'otan sont réunis
depuis 10h ce matin et s'attarde vista
top parce que on s'occupe des détails
maintenant les serbes devront retirer
leur artillerie a combien de kilomètres
on dit 20 km ça peut être 25 ou 30
on discute là dessus cette injonction
c'est sur combien de jours
cet ultimatum alors on peut qu'on dit
dix jours mais ça peut être celle
janvier on discute surtout là dessus
donc ce qui est important en tout cas
c'est que les 16 membres de longtemps
vont lancer une injonction aux serbes de
bosnie en leur disant vous retirez vos
artillerie ou alors cette fois ci on
frappe
il y aura des bombardements et en même
temps quelques dans l'après midi on
apprenait que les serbes dirais mais
nous allons les retirer puisque nous
avons signé un accord de cessez-le-feu
avec les musulmans et que nous sommes
prêts à remettre nos armes lourdes à
l'onu
mais il ya déjà eu beaucoup de promesses
elles ont peu été tenus ou même pas du
tout donc
l'otan a décidé de maintenir sa pression
sur les serbes lors donc cette
injonction dure toujours et durera
jusqu'à jusqu'à son terme
8 7 10 jours c'est ce qu'on sera dans la
soirée merci philippe évidemment vous
resterait vigilant tout au long de la
soirée pour nos téléspectateurs
c'est donc la fin de ce journal si vous
voulez voir les effets d'un licenciement
sans préavis pour un cadre supérieur
regardez le film de maurice friedland
sur france 2 à 22h50 avec les excellents
patrick chesnais pascal rocard son titre
assedic mans votre philippe lefait vous
présentera le dernier journal
00h10 et vous donnera les dernières
nouvelles sur bruxelles et la bosnie et
sophie davant vous précisera dans
quelques instants les couleurs très
diverses du temps de demain bonne soirée
sur france 2 adema 20h bonsoir